[Musique]
pour moi on m'offre un cadeau c'est
assez rare pour le souligner un jour un
cadeau assez gentil ça d'avoir pensé à
moi bon il est pas très bien emballé
faut avouer mais c'est l'intention qui
compte
j'adore les cadeaux de noël et surprise
on y rajoute des patients ça me fait
trop plaisir mais vraiment mais j'adore
c'est trop génial
j'en fais trop en plus mais c'est
magnifique
allez pas me gâter comme ça c'est super
mignon un petit cochon petite [ __ ]
pour dormir
ouais mais c'est formidable
ddm magnifique merci asensi relire
j'avais pas vu mais c'est vrai que je
suis un peu dépensière un des indes et
vraiment c'est meilleur cadeau de ma vie
franchement je te remercie c'est le
meilleur cadeau que j'ai vu de ma vie
entière
je peux l'essayer voilà là mais c'est
trop beau geste à faire comme ça pour
voir
voilà ça me va à merveille jean portal
est comme ça quand j'étais jeune
j'adore ça j'allais perdre une bien
j'avais j'avais à la fin je les paumés
et voilà donc je suis super content de
retrouver un
voilà c'est comme ça je vais pouvoir
dormir pendant l'émission et dès que je
sors
merci en fait c'est la carte du monde
c'est bien j'aime bien voyager donc
c'est c'est vachement bien
en plus avec gilles non mais rien ne
pouvait me faire plus plaisir qu'il a eu
l'idée m'a dit je suis super ravie
merci oui bah du coup en fait je te voir
où sont les pays que j'aimerais bien
visiter voilà super merci ça pour elle
alors là rien ne pouvait me faire plus
plaisir merci vous coups partent
s'installer en moi voilà en tout cas
c'est super gentil je sais pas qui a
pensé mais voilà vous avez entre les
baisers super seven personnes au coeur
je suis ravi du cochon la thaïlande par
exemple mon prochain pays bas coût de
main merci je sais pas quoi dire je suis
ému c'est en tout cas ce que tu me
connais vraiment bien si c'est ça je
pense que le bonheur
merci c'est un match vraiment qu'ils
sont identiques simple paire de jumeaux
d'idées